[Música]
muy buenas tardes le damos la bienvenida
a un nuevo avance informativo de france
24 que comenzamos precisamente en
francia donde fuentes de la policía
local confirmaron que un hombre fue
decapitado en las afueras de la capital
en un hecho que ya es investigado por
las autoridades antiterroristas el
ataque ocurrió en la localidad de
hernani a unos 30 km de parís
el atacante falleció tras recibir
disparos de la policía
fuentes de la fiscalidad nacional
antiterroristas confirmaron que ya se
abrió una investigación por asesinato y
se sabe que el fallecido era un maestro
de escuela que habría mostrado
caricaturas del profeta mahoma en clase
algo que los musulmanes consideran una
blasfemia y el presidente emmanuel
macrón ya se hizo presente en el lugar
de los hechos nuestros compatriotas
hay telas mont nuestro compatriota fue
cobardemente atacado ha sido la víctima
de un atentado terrorista de corte
islamista islamista carácter
esta noche yo quiero antes que nada
acompañar en su dolor a sus allegados a
su familia acompañar en su dolor a sus
compañeros aquí en el colegio
continuamos con noticias sobre la
carrera hacia la casa blanca y es que un
día después de que donald trump show
bardem rivalizarán simultáneamente por
la atención de los votantes en dos
programas de televisión que reemplazaron
al debate virtual los candidatos
continúan hoy con sus campañas de cara a
las elecciones del 3 de noviembre baiden
llegó a michigan mientras que donald
grandes de florida dedicó parte de su
discurso a captar el voto de los adultos
mayores estoy moviendo el cielo y la
tierra para proteger nuestros adultos
mayores del virus de china y brindar
terapias que salvan vidas en un tiempo
récord y distribuir una vacuna segura y
efectiva antes de fin de año sonarán a
las personas mayores serán las primeras
en la fila para recibir la vacuna y así
terminaremos con esta pandemia y en
otras noticias salvador cienfuegos
estamos hablando del general mexicano ex
secretario de defensa
del gobierno de enrique peña nieto-
arrestado en eeuu está siendo acusado de
cargos vinculados al narcotráfico y
otros delitos la fiscalía federal del
distrito este de nueva york acusó este
viernes de narcotráfico al ex
funcionario arrestado el jueves en los
ángeles tres de los cargos están
relacionados con la producción el
tráfico y la distribución de
estupefacientes mientras que el cuarto
está vinculado al blanqueo de dinero
según un documento de la fiscalía por su
parte el presidente mexicano andrés
manuel lópez obrador aseguró que se va a
investigar a todos los involucrados
todos los que resulten involucrados
en este otro asunto
el canal sin fuegos
que estén
actuando
en el gobierno
la secretaria de la defensa van a ser
suspendidos
retirados
sí
es el caso
puestos a disposición
de las autoridades
competentes gracias por acompañarnos
regresamos en breve con más noticias